hallo mein Name ist Sky du Mont und ich
präsentiere euch den dunklen Januar ein
Tatort Deutschland Spezial jeden Tag ein
neuer Kriminalfall
hallo und ich bin Natalie Strauß ich
freue mich dass ihr wieder dabei seid
auch heute drehen wir wieder in die
menschlichen Abgeordnete vor
in dieser Folge geht es um einen der
wahnwitzigsten und perfidesten
Kriminalfälle Deutschlands den
Bombenanschlag auf die Mannschaft von
Borussia Dortmund begangen von einem
Täter der bereit war für seine Habgier
über Leichen zu gehen zusammen mit
Sprechern Moderatorin Mirko Kasimir
traurig ein in diesen spannenden Fall
Bomben Terror statt Fußballfest hallo
Natalie und auch von mir ein herzliches
willkommen zu unserer heutigen Folge
[Musik]
es ist der 11 april 2017 19 Uhr die
Fußballmannschaft von Borussia Dortmund
macht sich auf den Weg zu ihrem
Champions-League Viertelfinal Heimspiel
gegen den AS Monaco es soll ein
bedeutender Fußballabend für die
Borussia werden
Trainer Thomas Tuchel und sein Team
verlassen das Hotel larivet im
Dortmunder Stadtteil höchsten mit ihrem
Mannschaftsbus
vom Hotel bis zum Stadion sind es 13 km
die Stimmung an Bord fokussiert
konzentriert eine angespannte Ruhe
herrscht den 28 Passagieren steht ein
wichtiges Spiel bevor doch der Fußball
soll an diesem Abend keine Rolle spielen
der schwarze Mannschaftsbus des BVB
biegt in die wittbräucker Straße
nur wenige Sekunden später
explodieren drei Sprengsätze
drei Sprengsätze versteckt in einer
Hecke der Turnieren nur 10 Meter neben
dem Bus des BVB die Sprengkraft ist
gewaltig ein Fenster des Busses
zerbürste eine große Glasscherbe schießt
durch die Luft und bohrt sich in die
Kopflehne eines Sitzes
Spieler Marc bartra wird am rechten Arm
verletzt die Spieler und Betreuer werfen
sich in Panik auf den Boden ein Motorrad
Polizist der den bvb-bus begleitet
erleidet ein Knalltrauma
was für ein Horror und man muss sagen
was für ein unfassbares Wunder das bei
diesem Bombenanschlag niemand gestorben
ist aber es hätte auch anders ausgehen
können und es hätte vielleicht auch
anders ausgehen sollen zumindest dass
sich das Täters es ist offenbar seine
Absicht gewesen einen oder mehrere oder
sogar alle in diesem Bus zu töten
die drei Bomben sind so konstruiert dass
sie maximalen Schaden anrichten nicht
nur ist die Sprengkraft enorm die
bombenpakete sind zusätzlich mit 7 cm
langen und 15 Gramm schweren
Metallstiften bestückt die bei der
Detonation wie maschinengewehrkugeln
durch die Luft fliegen
mehrere Geschosse bohren sich in die
Hauswand auf der gegenüberliegenden
Straße Seite Glück für die Profis des
BVB die mittlere der drei Bomben ist zu
hoch angebracht die Wucht der Explosion
und die tödlichen Metallstifte dieser
Bombe fliegen zum großen Teil über den
Bus hinweg
der Schock nach diesem brutalen Anschlag
sitzt tief das Entsetzen ist den
Spielern und betreuen ins Gesicht
geschrieben dem Team von Borussia
Dortmund wird nach und nach klar es hat
soeben einen Bombenanschlag überlebt
schwer bewaffnete Polizisten erscheinen
am Tatort und bringen die Mannschaft in
Sicherheit
es ist einfach nur gruselig
10.000 Fans waren zu diesem Zeitpunkt
schon im Stadion in Vorfreude auf das
Spiel sie wurden dann nach und nach über
die furchtbaren Ereignisse informiert
zunächst schrieb der BVB um 19:40 Uhr
über Twitter dass es bei der Abfahrt des
Busses einen Vorfall gegeben habe der
Verein hielt sich also erstmal bedeckt
doch schon Minuten später tickerten die
Nachrichtenagenturen die
schock-nachricht um die Welt
Bombenanschlag auf die Mannschaft des
BVB an diesem Abend Fußball zu spielen
war also undenkbar 15 Minuten vor dem
geplanten Anpfiff oder das Spiel
abgesagt die große Frage war nun wer hat
diesen Anschlag verübt und warum
in der Nähe des Tatorts werden drei
textgleiche Bekennerschreiben gefunden
der Absender die Terrororganisation der
islamische Staat der nicht nur die
Verantwortung für diese Tat übernimmt
sondern auch weitere Anschläge in
Deutschland ankündigt
doch die Ermittler sind skeptisch
schließlich hat es bislang keine
Bekennerschreiben des islamischen
Staates gegeben
die Polizisten sollen Recht behalten ein
islamwissenschaftliches Gutachten
bezweifelt die Echtheit des Schreibens
wer auch immer das Bekennerschreiben
verfasst hat will nur den Eindruck
erwecken als seien hier islamistische
Terroristen am Werk
auch einem Internet veröffentlichtes
Bekennerschreiben der Antifa stellt sich
als unech heraus genauso wie die
Bekennerschreiben aus
rechtsextremistischen Kreisen
und jetzt beginnt das große Rätselraten
wenn es kein Terroranschlag war wer war
dann der Täter wer hat diese drei Bomben
gezündet wer wollte dass die Mannschaft
des BVB stirbt und was war das Motiv
auf die richtige Spur kam die Polizei
schließlich durch einen Mann aus
Österreich einem BVB-Fan der sich auch
für die Aktie des Fußballvereins
interessierte
[Musik]
dieser Mann ist selbstaktionär von
Borussia Dortmund er verfolgt den Handel
rund um die Aktie seines
Lieblingsvereins kurz vor der Tat fällt
ihm etwas Ungewöhnliches auf
jemand kauft hoch riskante
Optionsscheine die sogenannten
Put-Optionen sorgen dafür dass ein
Käufer hohe Gewinne einstreichen kann
wenn der Aktienkurs fällt
jemand wettet also gegen den BVB
jemand setzt viel Geld darauf dass der
Borussia Dortmund Aktienkurs in kurzer
Zeit stark sinkt
dies kommt dem Mann aus Österreich
zunächst nur verdächtig vor doch nach
dem Anschlag wird im klar der Käufer
dieser Option Scheine muss etwas mit dem
Bomben Terror zu tun haben
der Käufer muss ein Mitwisser oder
vielleicht sogar der Täter sein
mit dieser Erkenntnis wendet sich der
aufmerksame Österreicher an die Polizei
und so gerät Serge GW ins Visier der
Ermittler ein 28-Jähriger Elektriker aus
Freudenstadt der die deutsche und die
russische Staatsangehörigkeit besitzt
sein Ziel dem BVB maximalen Schaden
zufügen den Kurs der Dortmund Aktie zum
Absturz bringen und dann an der Börse
abkassieren
das ist echt heftig wie so oft ging es
also wieder nur um eins ums Geld
gehandelt und er hat seine Tat akribisch
geplant
Mirko lass uns kurz die Zeit
zurückdrehen und Sergey bei seinen
Vorbereitung beobachten
es ist der 9 april 2017
zwei Tage vor dem Anschlag bricht der
schmächtige 28-Jährige auf
er verlässt seine heimatfreuden statt
und fährt mit einem Mietwagen zum
bvb-mannschaft Hotel larivé in Dortmund
im Gepäck zwei Sporttaschen ein
Rollkoffer und eine große gefüllte
Plastiktüte alles was er für den
geplanten Anschlag braucht hat er dabei
fast alles auf seinem Weg hält der GW an
einer Tankstelle wo er noch einen
Kanister mit Benzin befüllt am
Nachmittag checkt er dann im
Mannschaftshotel ein sein Zimmer hat die
Nummer 402 es ist ein Zimmer mit Blick
zur Straße
Sergej wie wollte unbedingt ein Zimmer
mit straßenblick und dafür gab es auch
einen guten Grund aber alles der Reihe
nach der Täter war also im Hotel
angekommen für Sergey W heißt es jetzt
erstmal abwarten
warten auf den 11 April auf den Tag an
dem er seinen grausamen Plan endlich
würde umsetzen können
in den frühen Morgenstunden des 11 April
trifft sergewe seine letzten
Vorbereitungen in einem Waldstück am
Rand des Hotels setzt er seine bereits
vor gebauten Sprengsätze zusammen
die Bomben sind nun zündbereit
um seine Spuren zu verwischen setzt
sergewe sein Lager im Wald mit
benzinenbrand und deponiert die Bomben
in der Hecke an der Hoteleinfahrt
genau dort wo später der Mannschaftsbus
des BVB entlangfahren wird das alles
passiert am Morgen das elften april 2017
bis zum Anschlag am Abend hat es der
Gewehr also noch ein paar Stunden Zeit
und diese Zeit nutzt er wie die
Ermittler herausgefunden haben unter
anderem für einen Besuch im Bordell also
noch mal schön ablenken vor dem großen
Kuh am Abend
um kurz nach 19 Uhr ist es soweit
Sergey W steht am Fenster von Zimmer 402
mit straßenblick also mit perfektem
Blick auf das Geschehen er beobachtet
den abfahrenden Mannschaftsbus des BVB
mit dem Fernzünder in der Hand noch hat
er kein Verbrechen begangen
noch kann er sich entscheiden die Bomben
doch nicht zu zünden
doch Sergej zieht seinen Plan durch als
der Bus des BVB an der mit Bomben
präparierten Hecke vorbei fährt drückt
er den Auslöser die drei Bomben
detonieren
nach dem Anschlag verlässt sergewe
Hotelzimmer 402
in aller Seelenruhe spaziert er durchs
Hotel
der 28-Jährige geht ins Hotel-Restaurant
wo er sich ein Steak bestellt
danach geht der Mann der soeben einen
Bombenanschlag verübt hat zum Entspannen
in die Sauna
außerdem könnte sich eine Massage
boah da läuft es mir echt den Rücken
runter wie kaltblütig dieser Mann
vorgegangen ist erst eine Bombe zünden
ohne Rücksicht auf Verluste und dann
schön Wellness machen es ist unfassbar
Sergey ging es einfach nur ums Geld
diesen Mann waren Menschenleben völlig
egal seine Opfer waren verletzt und
traumatisiert aber er hatte gute Laune
denn Sergei hatte allen Grund zu glauben
dass er mit seinem Verbrechen
durchkommen würde
erwähnt sich nach der Tat in Sicherheit
schließlich gehen zunächst alle von
einem terroristischen Attentat aus
begangen entweder von Islamisten von
links oder rechtsextremen die Presse
überschlägt sich mit Spekulationen zu
einem möglichen Terroranschlag von einem
Einzeltäter ist nicht die Rede die
Schlagzeilen in den Zeitungen und die
Spekulationen in den sozialen Medien
geben
ein gutes Gefühl
scheinbar sind alle auf der falschen
Spur
was er nicht weiß die Ermittler der
Polizei haben Sergey W bereits wenige
Tage nach der Tat im Visier ja ihm wurde
zum Verhängnis dass es in Österreich
diesen einen Mann gab dem aufgefallen
ist dass da jemand am Aktienmarkt im
großen Stil gegen den BVB wettet dieser
Mann gab der Polizei den entscheidenden
Tipp wobei der Täter noch nicht sofort
festgenommen wurde
bis zu seiner Verhaftung wird sergewe
von den Ermittlern beschattet sie wollen
herausbekommen ob der Täter Komplizen
hat und weitere Beweise sammeln da der
Aktienkurs von Borussia Dortmund wieder
erwarten doch nicht einbricht und der
große Reibach für ihn ausbleibt macht
sich sehr GW kurz nach der Tat auf die
Suche nach einem neuen Anschlagsziel
er googelt seilbahnaktie
Berchtesgadener Bergbahn und
optionsscheinfinder
doch Serge W wird nicht mehr lange ein
freier Mann sein
nachdem er einen Flug nach St Petersburg
Bucht vermuten die Polizisten dass er
sich absetzen möchte
bevor dies geschehen kann erfolgt der
Zugriff am 21 april 2017 wird sergew auf
dem Weg zu seiner Arbeit verhaftet
der Verdächtige gibt die Tat sofort zu
na es wäre aber auch schwer gewesen dass
alles abzustreiten ich meine die
Beweislage die war mehr als einfach nur
erdrückend erstens Sergey W war als
Hotelgast am Tatort eingecheckt zweitens
er hat 15.000 Optionsscheine gegen den
BVB gekauft und drittens diese
Optionsscheine kaufte er über die
IP-Adresse des Hotels also sich daraus
zu reden dass wir ein Ding der
Unmöglichkeit
im August 2017 erhebt die
Staatsanwaltschaft Dortmund Anklage
gegen sergewe ihm wird versuchter Mord
vorgeworfen insgesamt 16 Nebenkläger
schließen sich der Klage an darunter
diverse Spieler des BVB der beim
Anschlag am Arm verletzte Marc bartra
sagt im Verfahren ich hatte Todesangst
ich fürchtete meine Familie nie wieder
zu sehen
ähnlich erschüttert äußert sich Torhüter
Roman Weidenfeller er sagt der Vorfall
hat mein Leben verändert
Marcel Schmelzer erklärt ich zucke noch
immer zusammen wenn irgendwo ein Teller
runterfällt oder wenn Fahrzeuge langsam
an uns vorbeifahren
Sergey Weg steht vor Gericht die Tat
bestreitet aber dass er die Absicht
hatte jemanden zu töten viel mehr habe
er die Sprengladungen absichtlich so
präpariert dass kein Mensch zu Schaden
kommen würde
doch diese Argumentation zählt nicht ein
Gutachten wird in Auftrag gegeben dass
die Behauptung von sergewe schließlich
widerlegt außerdem sagt ein Mithäftling
aus sergiw habe ihm verraten dass er bei
dem Anschlag so viele Menschen wie
möglich töten wollte
also die Beweislage war erdrückend der
Täter war geständig und so kam es wie es
kommen musste segw wurde verknackt
am 27 November 2018 verurteilt das
Landgericht Dortmund ihn wegen
versuchten 28-fachen maudes wegen
schwerer Körperverletzung und wegen der
Herbeiführung einer Sprengstoffexplosion
er muss für 14 Jahre ins Gefängnis
der Verurteilte habe aus Habgier
gehandelt er wird als vollschuldfähig
eingestuft der Bombenanschlag auf den
Mannschaftsbus von Borussia Dortmund ist
damit aufgeklärt einer der
hinterhältigsten und kaltblütigsten
kriminellen Deutschlands muss für sehr
lange Zeit hinter Gitter
ja der Fall ist aufgeklärt kannst du den
Akten aber ein paar Fragen haben wir
noch oder Mirko ja ich frage mich zum
Beispiel was eigentlich passiert wäre
wenn es nicht diesen aufmerksamen
Aktionär aus Österreich gegeben hätte
wenn der sich nicht bei der Polizei
gemeldet hätte wären die Beamten dann
trotzdem auf sergewe aufmerksam geworden
wären sie auf ihn aufmerksam geworden
bevor er einen weiteren Anschlag hätte
begehen können denn offenbar war er ja
schon dabei sein nächstes Ziel
auszukundschaften ja darüber bin ich
auch gestolpert das ist sehr GW so kurz
nach der Tat schon ein neues Verbrechen
geplant hat zeigt mir dass er alles
andere als zufrieden damit war viel der
bvb-anschlag gelaufen ist es ist niemand
ums Leben gekommen der Kurs der Dortmund
als hier ist nicht abgestürzt und ich
vermute er hat sich sehr darüber
geärgert stell dir mal vor seine Bombe
hätte tatsächlich mehrere Spieler in den
Tod gerissen dann wäre die Aktie
abgestürzt und Serge weh hätte richtig
abkassiert
ja sehr GW wollte wohl unbedingt reich
werden und dafür war bereit über Leichen
zu gehen ob nun über eine über zehn oder
auch über 28 Leichen das war ihm einfach
egal ja das war ein total egal der ganze
Anschlag war ein Verbrechen wie aus
einem Film
perfides grublos präzise geplant aber
glücklicherweise dennoch erfolglos aber
manchmal reicht eben auch ein winzig
kleines Puzzlestück oder ein einziger
Mensch aus um den Stein ins Rollen zu
bringen und einen Täter zu überführen
und wieder ist klar geworden dass
perfekte Verbrechen gibt es wohl nicht
zum Glück und ich hoffe so sehr für den
Fan aus Österreich dass sich der BVB
gebührend bei ihm bedankt hat
liebe Zuhörer und ZuhörerInnen das war
schon wieder bei Tatort Deutschland
Spezial wir freuen uns wenn ihr dann
auch bei der nächsten Folge wieder dabei
seid bis dahin euer Mirko auch eure
Natalie
die Ereignisse des 11 april 2017 und es
späteren Prozesses haben wir mit
zahlreichen tagesaktuellen Artikeln aus
Bild Welt Gießener allgemeine
Süddeutsche Zeitung der Website bvb.de
sowie Einträgen aus Wikipedia nachher
zielt Redaktion Stefan Netzeband und
Antonia Heiler Produktion Marvin schwarz